here on this video we will compare
seven scenes that are very similar in
the two movies that
feature gom and godzilla fighting one
another
the first movie was released way back in
1962
and the monsters were actually people
and costumes
and in the second one godzilla vs kong
of 2021
the monsters were fully cgi with motion
capture
nevertheless there were scenes of the
recent movie
that were very eerily similar to the
classic monster mashup
so let us see which ones they were and
discuss a little bit on this
so let's get down with this sickness the
first one which we like to dub
as godzilla attack scene features the
g-man in a 1962 movie
surfacing from the ocean and attacking a
military installation
there were rockets and artillery shot at
him and him attacking and destroying the
base with his atomic breath
in the same way godzilla in this year's
movie surfaces from the ocean to attack
an apex facility in pensacola in florida
to destroy the bays that house skull
crawlers and make a godzilla parts
the similarity in both scenes is that
godzilla comes out from the ocean
was attacked by humans and uses his
atomic breath to destroy the human
facilities
the second one is the one where comb is
in the ocean and we dubbed this as the
kong transported scene
in the 1962 movie king kong was put to
sleep as a result of over-consuming
berry juice
that intoxicated him and caused him to
black out
therefore humans were able to transport
him using a wooden wrath
and tied him up using ropes similarly in
godzilla vs kong
kong had to be transported from skull
island the containment zone to
antarctica
and he was sedated in order for monarch
to be able to chain him up
and put him on a large container ship to
ferry the giant ape to the hollow earth
travel location so back to the 1962
movie kong went on a rampage in japan
and had to be put to sleep again to be
able to transport him to the fight
against godzilla
in this part they used helium balloons
and helicopters to take him to mount
fuji
where he would have the ultimate fight
against the g-man this is what we call
the kong helicopter scene
in 2021 kong had had a fight with
godzilla in the ocean
and was nearly drowned this left him
exhausted and in order for monarch
to be able to take him safely to
antarctica without further aggravating
godzilla
he had to utilize helicopters and osprey
aircrafts
to ferry the big ape for the remaining
distance
this next scene is kind of funny in both
movies we call it the godzilla eats a
tree scene
in the fight on mount fuji in a 1962
movie king kong managed to block the
atomic breath of godzilla by
ramming a tree into his mouth that
causing the big g to choke on it a
little bit
and later free himself and eventually
shoot the atomic breath at king kong
in 2021 in the fight in hong kong khan
did the same move to block the atomic
breath by ramming the axe handle into
godzilla's mouth
right before he shoots his iconic power
and same as in the 1962 movie godzilla
choked on it a little bit but
immediately
afterwards shoots the atomic breath at
kong
so next here in the scene in the classic
movie
which we call the kong sneak attack
scene king kong after knocking godzilla
down
ran and hid behind a rock wall and
sneaked attack godzilla who was in
search of him
but that didn't work out as he was
knocked over in godzilla versus gong
after the initial round of fights
between the two tyrants
and kong knocking out godzilla the g-man
manages to get back up and was searching
for kong
but the giant ape did the same thing and
sneaked attacked godzilla but was taken
down
and this led to godzilla overpowering
him and thus winning the fight
so next in both movies kong was nearly
killed and had to be revived to continue
to fight
the resurrection scene is what we call
it and in 1962 king kong was down for
the count and was
buried in rocks by godzilla but by a
stroke of luck there was lightning and a
couple of these struck
the body of king kong therefore reviving
him and actually made him stronger
in godzilla vs kong the nuclear lizard
manages to bring down
kong with his powerful stump on kong's
chest he actually kind of gave korma
cardiac arrest
cow nearly died if not for nathan lynn
using the heav
to create a power such that acted as a
defibrillator
and restores gong's heartbeat and
lastly the ending scene this is
practically the same in both movies with
one of the monsters
swimming away after the big fight of
course in 1962 king kong was seen
swimming away after the fight with
godzilla
godzilla was never seen doing the same
but in 2021 they corrected this and
instead of kong swimming away
it was godzilla that went away in the
same manner which makes more sense as he
was more of an aquatic titan than kong
so both of them fought and survived at
the end of both movies
and so with that we come to the end of
this video do click that like button for
support and that subscribe button to be
a part of the mind cue family
and also smash that notification bell
for regular updates on godzilla vs
common dissection videos
monster and kaiju content right here on
minecube
take care fam